Kim fields is at trading in the drama of  The Real Housewives of Atlanta this is  Dancing with the Stars for the drama of  the ballroom yes  et sources can exclusively confirm the  46 year old actress is joining the cast  of Dancing with the Stars upcoming at  22nd season ABC will make the official  announcement along with the rest of the  cast on Good Morning America  on March 8 we do know two faces Kim  won't be seeing in the ballroom though  Julianne Hough is not returning as a  judge she did three seas great seasons  and it's time for her to go and Allison  Holker won't be back as a pro definitely  not a possibility I I always try to look  at myself as a superhero like a  superwoman I could do anything and I can  make it back but I'll probably be in the  delivery room like during the premiere  of the show